nos piden que factor hicimos para
agrupación esta expresión que tenemos
aquí 5 rs más 25 r menos 3 s menos 15 y
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que tenemos cuatro términos y además
no tenemos un factor común de todos
ellos por ejemplo estos dos son
divisibles entre 5 pero menos 3 ese
nombre está es divisible entre r esta
división de entre er pero estos dos
nombres 5 rs y menos 3 s son divisibles
en 13 pero los otros dos no y por lo
tanto no hay un factor común de todos
así que lo que voy a hacer es factorizar
por agrupación y para factorizar por
agrupación lo que hay que fijarnos es en
los primeros dos términos ya factorizar
lo más que se pueda y después en los
segundos dos términos y de ahí
factorizar lo más que se pueda así que
vamos a hacerlo vamos a fijarnos primero
en estos dos en cinco rs 25d ver y de
aquí vamos a factorizar lo más que se
pueda y si te das cuenta estos dos
tienen quinta y además tienen r por lo
tanto lo más que se puede factorizar
estos dos
r así que déjenme escribirlo aquí abajo
5 r es lo más que se puede factorizar 5
r que multiplica que en 5 rs entre 5 r
pues me dan ese y después tengo 25 r
entre 5 r
esto me da 5 y tú lo puedes comprobar
multiplicando 5 r por ese 5 y tienes que
llegar a 5 rs 25 r 5 por 5 25 y creo que
está aquí vamos bien después tengo 5
eres mi factor común que multiplica a es
más 5 pero ahora me voy a fijar en los
siguientes dos términos en estos dos y
de aquí voy a factorizar también lo más
que se pueda y seguramente te estás
dando cuenta que lo más que se puede
actualizar es un 31 más tres o uno menos
tres sin embargo voy a usar el menos
tres para que adentro del paréntesis
después de que realice la factorización
por el factor común me quede algo muy
parecido a ese más 5 y para esto
necesito que adentro del paréntesis sean
positivos por lo tanto voy a factorizar
en menos 3 y me quedan menos 3 es entre
menos 3 me da s
y después menos 15 entre menos 3 menos
entre menos nada más 15 entre 35
entonces me quedan ese 5 y justo en este
momento seguramente hay algo que ya te
está saltando a simple vista aquí hay
algo muy parecido de estos dos
paréntesis pero antes de eso lo que
quiero que veas es que si tú tienes
dudas ya factorizar o bien lo que puedes
hacer es distribuir ambos productos para
ver si llega a ser lo mismo si tú
distribuyese 5r y el -3 tendrás que
llegar a la expresión que tenemos aquí
arriba pero bueno lo que quiero que veas
es que aquí hay algo muy parecido
tenemos ese más 5 como factor común es
más 5 es nuestro factor común porque en
este momento es más 5 está multiplicando
tanto a 5 r como menos 3 aunque sea un
binomio es un milagro que se repite y
que está multiplicando a su vez a 5 efe
ya menos 3 por lo tanto qué te parece si
lo agarramos como factor común y me
queda ese más 5 que multiplica quién
bueno en primer lugar va a multiplicar a
5 r eso es lo que dice la parte de
amarillo es más 5 multiplica a 5 r pero
por otra parte por la parte de morado
es más 5 también multiplica al menos 3
por lo tanto me queda es más 5 que en
primer lugar multiplica 5 r y después
multiplica menos 3 y ya está ya tengo mi
factorización por agrupación y para
comprobarlo tú lo puedes ver de la
siguiente manera podremos multiplicar
ese 5 primero por 5 r y después por
menos 3 y llegaríamos la expresión que
tenemos aquí arriba y después podríamos
multiplicar 5 r por s más 5 y
llegaríamos a esto que tenemos aquí y
menos 3 por s más 5 y llegaríamos a
nuestros últimos dos términos de morada